bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors plusieurs milliers de
personnes battent le pavé actuellement
un peu partout en france à l'appel
notamment de la cgt
avec quel bilan vous faites tout de
suite sur cette première journée
d'action depuis la rentrée la coûteuse
c'est le bilan c'est que contrairement à
ce que prétend le gouvernement
il ya encore beaucoup de salariés qui
sont en colère aujourd'hui le fait que
les contre-réforme des retraites ou de
l'assurance chômage soit suspendu et
seulement suspendu bas ne suffit pas et
beaucoup de salariés aujourd'hui battre
le pavé ont leur retraite définitif
après il ya aussi les promesses qui ont
été faites pendant la crise au plus fort
de la crise du coc vide pendant le
confinement disant que personne ne sera
laissé sur le chemin qui aura des
moratoire sur les licenciements etc
on voit qu'aujourd'hui il ya quasiment
un million un million et demi de
chômeurs de plus on voit qu'il ya des
grands groupes qui se gagnent d'argent
public a comme peugeot ou renault
auchan qui licencient à tour de bras on
voit que dans des entreprises où ça ne
licencie pas peut-être mais où il ya du
blocage des salaires et des attaques
contre les conditions de travail et bien
évidemment les salariés répondent ils
ont bien raison
donc par la grève pour certains dans la
rue encore ou à mon avis on est un petit
peu plus que les 4 1999 qu'on devrait
être on est là dans la rue dans le
respect des gestes barrières bien sûr
mais on est dans la rue pour exprimer
notre colère et nos revendications
alors parmi les revendications justement
on retrouve notamment une hausse des
salaires
compte tenu du contexte sanitaire et
économique actuelle est ce que c'est
opportun
écoutez les profits existent ils sont
rangés les entreprises du cac40
fonctionne elle fonctionne plutôt bien
il y en a même qui ont fait des profits
considérables il ya eu ce qu'on était
soi-disant en guerre il ya eu des
profiteurs de guerre je pense notamment
dans le commerce
moi je pose la question aujourd'hui très
tranquillement quand le groupe carrefour
qui a reçu des centaines de millions
d'euros dus au titre du cic donc pour
créer des emplois soit 10 ans et qui
licencient 1400 personnes alors qu'ils
ont fait des profits considérables
pendant le confinement est bien faut se
poser quand même un peu la question
ils aiment l'argent public ils aiment
l'argent public pour ça ils n'aiment pas
en donner un
je remarque que la famille mulliez qui
est pdg du groupe carrefour qui sont
dirigeants du groupe carrefour vivent en
belgique et paye ne payent pas leurs
impôts sur le revenu en france donc il
n'aime pas payer d'impôts mais il aime
bien l'argent public et on échange de
quoi les licencie les gens 1400
personnes en on l'a dit des travailleurs
qui ont été en première ligne
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit la
famille mulliez est déchargé les
palettes pendant le coït
mais on a la même chose avec la famille
peugeot qui allaitent en suisse où avec
bernard arnault aussi qui est dans le
plat pays
et quand on voit qu'on donne 5 milliards
d'euros à renault et qui ne virent pas
pratiquement cinq mille personnes
c'est à dire ah ah
milliers d'emplois supprimés par
milliards qu'on leur donne voilà c'est
absolument inadmissible
le lendemain de l' annonce des 5
milliards et des licenciements
je rappelle tout le groupe renault a
bondi l'action renault a bondi de 18% à
la bourse
donc il ya des effets d'aubaine ya de
l'argent est bien la question c'est de
sa répartition alors le nombre de
contaminations koffi 19 est en
augmentation constante alors on a
peut-être perdu notre invité oui ou non
est ce qu'on peut me répondre
alors on a effectivement vous m'entendez
oui je vous entends parfaitement
alors on va peut-être continuer alors le
nombre de contaminations commis 19 est
en constante augmentation la menace
d'une deuxième vague plane sur la france
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à d'autres
manifestations de ce type d'envergure
dans les prochaines semaines et est ce
que c'est vraiment raisonnable écoutez
j'ai trouvé absolument provocateur c'est
une évidence et plus ou moins tout au
moins scandaleux l'interpellation de
monsieur djebbari qui dit que c'est une
grève et une manifestation irresponsable
en pleine période du coronavirus
m'attendait le patronat lui lâche ses
coups il nie 106 à tour de bras il
compresse les salaires il attaque les
organisations du travail et les
conditions de travail lui le patronat ne
respectent pas cette idée d'unité
nationale donc nous salariés nous
n'allons pas nous laisser faire sous
prétexte coronavirus alors que le
patronat lui lâche ses coups à un moment
donné faut être sérieux
ou alors on nationalise ont fait un
moratoire on interdit les licenciements
collectifs
on retire les mesures antisociales et là
effectivement le gouvernement serait
légitime a demandé qu'on arrête de
manifester mais n'allons pas nous faire
les et de nos droits démocratiques alors
qu'on est dans une crise sociale quasi
sans précédent depuis l'après-guerre
sous prétexte de coronavirus l'aficion
est un petit peu grosse eh bien ce sera
le mot de la fin mathieu ball red hat
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire de la
section de trappes et de versailles de
la cgt cheminots